kind of ran out of time but I want to
show you these new puppets they have
yeah what happened to the puppet I got
him from me and Fred I got a new Ronnie
puppet how can I so he doesn't have to
use the Ronnie on a stick
no no this one's really awesome and I
got a JD puppet - JD puppet
yeah I'm testing out a new concept Oh
the show is going all puppet dad we're
going all puppy
we won't even have to show up at some
point it's gonna be like a Muppets kind
of it's our it's our rebirth but I know
if I show you this puppet now Fred
you're gonna start working it and I'm
gonna start doing JD
yabba now or later it'll be an hour so
let's just wait for Monday okay I'll
show you don't show Fred okay won't work
oh that's hysterical [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
look at the beard is all these hair
colors a different color I love the hair
in the sideburns yeah you damn right you
love it the puppets taller but this
one's for you Freddy's you do and I'll
do the JD puppet I'll be like it looks
like he could be Ronnie's son
I heard those two arguing in the hall
yesterday oh really
I was thinking of Fred and I can reenact
what is he Gary to Fred okay yeah well
you know we're gonna get started oh here
we go
this is what you weren't supposed to do
Gary all right a little tryout and the
London will really work these puppets
but JD was in his office Ronnie came by
and he goes you know JD was voicing a
real complaint like I don't I don't
leave your paper and then Ronnie goes
hey [ __ ] you I need you yeah
[ __ ] let me see your puppet yeah
Ronnie took me in a Steven thing and I
got my ring I feel like my JD impression
is not good JD why were you fighting
with Ronnie I wouldn't fight Irani put
his newspaper on my thing and I thought
he was giving it to me
and I said I don't want this newspaper
and it Ronnie was like no I'm taking the
newspaper back Ronnie yeah well I'm
taking newspaper back you big loser
what happened someone mentioned Peter
Frampton to you and you freaked out JD
your dad's into Peter Frampton or
something and he started yelling at
Jason because Jason Kaplan is on my ass
with every [ __ ] thing my dad is into
Peter Frampton and asked for a ticket
you know was wanting to see if I could
get him into the show whenever he goes
to Cincinnati and so I emailed someone
here and it wasn't a Jason and then all
of a sudden next thing I know what do I
do
can I do he doesn't know about you know
JD the whole time you're talking Howard
was working your puppet thank you it was
great
and Jason Kaplan
[Laughter]